thanks Andy good afternoon everyone
my name is Karthik raghunathan and this
is sarah she ragu and she we are both
part of the WebEx intelligence group at
Cisco this is the group that works on
building machine learning driven
intelligent experiences for all of
Cisco's WebEx portfolio of collaboration
products we are both really excited to
be here as part of the computer systems
colloquium it this is this is a course
that I myself took in my very first
quarter here as a Stanford master
student about a decade ago and I think
it was pretty useful for me to just get
the breadth of all the different leading
challenges in the industry and it helped
me put my academics in perspective so
I'm really happy to be back here after
about ten years and sharing like some of
our industry learnings with all of you
so the talk today is about building
enterprise level conversational
interfaces and at a high level the talk
is structured into two main parts I'll
be beginning with a overview of what
vivexx intelligences which is the
initiative that ara she and I are a part
of and this would mainly just to be for
setting the stage for a rest of the talk
once we have given you some background
about the kind of products we are trying
to build will the remainder of the talk
will just be a technical deep dive into
some of the practical problems we are
solving specifically in the area of
conversational AI so we will go over
various natural language processing
techniques for building conversational
interfaces for the interface for the
enterprise we will talk about how do you
go about doing training data collection
for training your statistical natural
language processing models how do you
build the end-to-end application and
then we will also touch upon how can you
improve your machine learning models
over time and thereby improve the
application over time as more and more
users use your system by the end of the
talk we hope to give everyone a good
overview and a good understanding of
what it takes to build
fairly complex conversational systems
like the personnel the various personal
assistants that are popular on the
market today and we also hope to be able
to give a better appreciation for some
of the challenges that these kind of
systems have to face especially when
dealing with voice inputs all right so
let me just start with a very quick
introduction about WebEx intelligence so
my alternate top my alternate title for
this section would have been really
Cisco works on AI because this is
something that seems to surprise a lot
of people and given Cisco's roots which
can actually be traced back to the
Stanford campus it's not a big surprise
that most people still associate Cisco
as just a networking hardware company
most people don't even think that's as
good as anything in the software space
let alone anything to do with machine
learning or AI but in reality cisco
makes a fair chunk of its revenue from
selling software to enterprise customers
the most popular of which is their
collaboration products that it sells
under the WebEx brand name some of you
may have already used WebEx most likely
the WebEx meetings application that
people use for hosting and conducting
online meetings but WebEx also has
solutions for messaging calling and
various forms of video conferencing so
from the kind of the Cisco desk phone
and the White House to the really large
telepresence devices and the corporate
boardrooms of various fortune finded
companies and everything in between
there are many millions of papers we use
who use Cisco's collaboration products
on a daily basis and what V as the WebEx
Intelligence Group are trying to do is
figuring out how we can leverage AI to
in general yeah make the lives of all
our users better and make them a lot
more productive as they use the WebEx
poor WebEx portfolio of products a lot
of the day-to-day collaboration these
days both within teams and across teams
happens within meetings and we envision
that using AI we can make this
experience much better
all of our users before during and after
the meetings so for instance we could
help our users figure out who are the
right people or the right set of
participants or subject matter experts
in the company to even invite to a
meeting to have a fruitful discussion on
a specific topic we could make sure that
we can automatically find the time and
schedule the meeting for them for
finding a time that's convenient for all
the different participants in advance of
the meeting we could also send them some
sort of pre briefing notes which could
be useful for them to be better prepared
and have a more productive meeting
during the course of the meeting we can
use AI techniques to make sure that the
meeting goes in the most smoothest and
seamless way possible we could possibly
also use AI to replace some of the work
that distracts humans in meetings today
such as note-taking or other kinds of
bookkeeping and finally once the meeting
is done we could leverage a technologies
to do things like automatically
generating meeting transcripts minutes
of the meeting summaries action items
and then send it to all the participants
so everyone is on the same page on what
the next steps are what the follow-up
actions are and so on some of these
capabilities are already achievable
today with a fairly reliable accuracy
some other capabilities work but they
work well only in some sort of ideal
conditions but just given the rapid pace
of progress and machine learning and
associated applied fields like speech
recognition natural language processing
and computer vision I think it's only a
matter of time before a lot of these
capabilities become a widespread reality
and just to drive that point home point
to whom I want to give a few examples of
some machine learning based applications
that are already successful in
production today so at this moment we
have fairly good complex computer vision
models which do a really good job at
face detection they are fairly robust
and they can detect faces of different
kinds different complexions size
in different environments so whether
it's a very small conference room or a
large auditorium like this one they do a
very good job of detecting all the faces
in the given image or the given video
stream we can can you do it and so forth
so you would have had to have at least
seen the camera head on once and then we
can do object detection and person
tracking to make sure it's the same
person but yeah but if you always we're
in the meeting not showing your face
then it would be difficult to do it yeah
yeah yeah and yeah so the face detection
models help us to yeah figure out do
some certain sort of runs conference
room analytics so we can figure out for
any given meeting what are the number of
participants who are better who've
joined in from different locations we
also use face detection for doing
intelligent framing which means we try
to crop and zoom into the relevant
portions of the room so that we can get
the best best sort of image and that in
general enhances the video-calling
experience similarly we also leverage
audio triangulation techniques in
conjunction with the microphone arrays
to figure out where the primary source
of audio in the room is coming from that
allows us to know who the active speaker
is and then make sure that the active
speaker is again tracked in every frame
of the image we also have models for
face recognition which is slightly
different than face detection in the
sense that in addition to detecting the
faces it's also classifying those faces
and assigning a name label to each one
of them so it can do a look up against a
trained set of person names from the
company directory and assign a name to
all the faces that it detects in the
meeting and you can foresee this being
really useful for scenarios where you
are meeting with a set of people for the
very first time so you already know who
each person is
so yeah I think dealing dealing with
background noise and ensuring the
crispest audio quality possible-- is is
a problem that all online meeting
software have to deal with and while
there's a lot of audio processing
techniques you can use for doing things
like echo cancellation canceling
reverberation and attenuating background
noise it it's it is still a challenging
problem to solve when let's say you have
a user who is dialed into the conference
room and has forgotten to put himself on
mute and then some of the inadvertent
noises that come from him disturb the
whole all the other users but we have
been in the past being able to solve
this with some amount of success by
training a supervised deep neural
network which is able to distinguish
human voices from other kinds of noises
such as the noise made from keyboard
keyboard taps or the noise of a dog
barking or a baby crying in the
background so anytime our classifier
detects any of those non-human voices
coming from a user we can now tell the
user that hey I'll just alert them that
we are detecting a lot of disturbing
noise from yours from your machine you
may want to put yourself on mute or we
might also be you able to use this to
just automatically kind of lower down
the volume for that user so yeah as you
can see there's like many different
varied applications of machine learning
just within the collaboration domain but
the topic that are she and I are mainly
going to be focusing on today is a
natural language understanding for
conversational assistants and the reason
this is a topic or this is an area that
our she and I have been working fairly
closely on for the past couple of years
and one of the reasons that this topic
is really exciting to us is that it's
increasingly becoming clear that
conversational interfaces are the next
frontier back in 2016
Google published a report saying that
almost 20 percent of all the searches it
gets our voice searches and then
comScore a
web analytics firm also mentioned that
by the end of next year they expect
almost half of all the web searches to
be initiated by a voice one other reason
for the proliferation one other reason
for yeah just this shift and user
behavior is the proliferation of
connected smart devices so now I think
almost 25 percent of all households in
the US have a voice enabled smart
speaker like Google home or the Amazon
echo and that number is steadily rising
so while we do see the adoption of
conversational interfaces go up in both
in home and even in cars the one place
which has generally been left out of the
whole conversationally revolution is the
workplace and this is the thing that we
at Cisco are trying to solve by trying
to build an assistant that we are
calling the WebEx assistant which is
more folk which is a new kind of
assistant focused merely on work use
cases so this is a first-of-its-kind
Enterprise focused assistant focused to
just help you get work done in a more
efficient way so that means that you may
not be able to ask this assistant to
sing a song or tell you a joke but if
you want to get things done like if you
want to join a meeting or schedule a
meeting or contact someone in the
company are you gonna share some files
with them or in general collaboration
collaboration with your colleagues this
is something that this wise assistant
will enable you to do a lot more
efficiently and seamlessly than before
so while we would have loved to do a
live demo of the WebEx assistant one of
the issues with that is that the WebEx
assistant
unlike the Google assistant or Siri or
Cortana doesn't actually live on a
mobile phone at least not yet right now
this is an assistant that resides in
Cisco's video conferencing devices like
the
device shown there so and it's difficult
for us to haul one of those big devices
here to do a demo but I do have some
screenshots and that I can walk through
just to give people just a little bit of
a glimpse into what the user experience
would look like so when you walk up to a
video conferencing unit the user
interface should resemble should look
something like this and then just as
with any otherwise assistant there is
usually a weak word to invoke it which
in our case the wake phrase is okay
WebEx so the moment you say okay WebEx
that puts the system into this listening
mode where it's waiting for the user to
speak his next voice command at this
point I could say something like call
Barbara and then the system takes this
voice command it tries to interpret it
using natural language processing in the
back end and then it understands that
the user is trying to call a person in
the company directory and then it
fetches the most relevant set of results
back to the user which is be showed in a
kind of results carousel like this so
here if I have already found the user
already found the colleague that I was
looking for I could go ahead and make
the selection but if I was not satisfied
with the first four set of results I
could say something like show more and
that would just show me the next page of
results and so you could similarly
expect like you could keep saying show
more or go back and you could just as
you navigate search results on a web
page you could navigate through through
this list of results so I could do this
over and over again till I actually find
the person I'm interested in and then
make the selection by saying something
like option 22 alternatively I could
have made the same selection by just
saying out the full name like I could
have just said Barbara Olga or I could
have said use used her title and say
it's something like Barbara the director
so anything that helps the system to
distinguish between the different
options being presented so regardless of
the way I make the selection what the
system would then do is go ahead and
actually make the call to the person and
then we can get our
eating started so this actually was a
little bit of a contrived example just
to show you what the user experience
looks like but in reality you would
never actually have to go all the way to
option 22 because the way our system
works is it it understands the user and
tries to cater the search results to the
user so it knows it has some notion of
the interaction is history of each user
and like how close is each user to other
users or other people other colleagues
in the company directory so it uses that
information to make sure that the people
you are more likely to interact with are
ranked way higher so in most cases you
would find the person you are looking
for right on the first page so that was
just a walkthrough of one one example
use case that you could do with WebEx
assistant but the assistant is actually
capable of handling more than upwards of
a hundred different user intents and so
what the rest of this talk is going to
be is just going behind the scenes of
how do you build a complex
conversational assistant like this one
or any of the other popular personal
assistants on the market that you may be
more familiar with and so I'll hand it
over to our 'she for the rest of the
talk and so as karthik mentioned i'll be
talking about some of the challenges
around and the solutions for building a
production level of conversational
assistant so building a truly good
conversational assistant is one of
today's hardest problems as i'm sure a
lot of you have experienced some of
today's chat bots can be fairly
disappointing you can say something like
call me an uber and the response will be
something like sorry i don't have a
contact for an uber in my address book
oftentimes these voice assistants can
misunderstand the common slang or they
can seem to break when you go even
slightly off script in addition even
basic requests that should be handled by
the assistant give the response of
something like sorry i don't
how to help with that on the other hand
in that yes yes so for the purpose of
this talk we're focusing on
english-language conversational
assistance and yes accents are a common
problem in speech recognition I guess
right out for the near term we're
focusing primarily only on English but
following that it'll be probably based
more on the customers and what languages
there have in their organizations it
turns out that even just with English we
are finding that the models that we
worked well for American English don't
quite work well for our British
customers or don't work quite well for
Indian customers right so even just
within English we are doing some tweaks
for each locale but then beyond that I
think we might mostly probably go to
some European languages and then
possibly Mandarin but yeah it would like
Irish she mentioned determined by the
kind of customer feedback so yeah while
today's chat bots are a difficult
problem in the academic world there's
been a lot of relevant progress with a
growing number of publicly available
datasets as well as a lot of recent
relevant papers being published in areas
like language modeling and dialogue
systems etc and furthermore some of
these papers have even reported near
human accuracy on certain sub tasks of
question answering or reading
comprehension so with all of these
advancements in the academic space why
is it still such a difficult problem to
build high-quality conversational
assistant and it comes down to a few
things one is that many of these
published papers focus on just a single
component of a larger problem so it
focuses just on reading comprehension or
just on question answering they don't
tell you how to string together all of
these components to prove to
create a full conversational app and as
you are stringing together these
different components you get a sort of
compounding error effect where if you're
reading comprehension module doesn't
fully understand what the user is trying
to say it makes it very difficult for
the question/answer to then respond back
with the answer that the user is
expecting in addition many of these
papers are evaluated on standardized
data sets and it can be very difficult
for you to build out a training data set
that has the amount of data that exists
in these standardized data sets and so
the state-of-the-art models that work
well on large training data sizes may
not work well on your smaller data sets
in addition the characteristics of these
data sets may be different your
real-world data sets may have more noise
or different types of noise than exists
and the standardized data sets that
these papers are being evaluated on and
so again the state-of-the-art models may
not necessarily translate in accuracy to
your specific use case yeah yes so I
guess that will be the next topic
so there's started to become a
consistent methodology that's emerging
for building conversational assistance
that yields good results and this is
kind of at a high level become an
industry standards that most of the
major players in the industry are using
and so the first step of that is data
collection the next step is a the
machine learning models and the
pipelines actually build the application
and the third is the concept of ongoing
model improvement how do you continually
improve your models over time so with
the first step of data collection the
first thing to think about is selecting
the right use case so as you narrow down
the domain of your use case you can
achieve higher accuracy more easily
because you can focus in on
domain-specific knowledge and vocab
however you also need your use case to
be broad enough that it's useful to the
users and it simulates kind of a
real-world human interaction so
selecting the right use cases finding
those cases that are both high accuracy
and strong value proposition so the
first set of data to be collected is
domain specific metadata so there's
three sub categories of this the first
is domain-specific vocabulary so if we
take these Starbucks coffee ordering use
case as an example some of the
domain-specific vocabulary are things
like Frappuccino macchiato venti
words that are very common in this
domain but very rare outside of it also
there's words like tall which means
something different in the Starbucks
ordering domain than it does in general
English language and so by collecting
large amounts of this domain vocabulary
you can tailor your models for the
specific language and data the next
category is data for a structured
knowledge base so this varies by use
case but it's essentially a structured
data set of all of the domain world
knowledge that you need to fulfill a
user's request so for the food ordering
use case this would be things like
restaurant names menus and dishes
options etc and for like a music
discovery use case it would be stuff
like song titles albums artists and a
lot of this data is often either
publicly available and can be scraped or
it can be consolidated VSM api's or may
be already available internally within
your organization but it's generally
something that you can compile
programmatically from what's already
existing in addition to the structure
database in a lot of use cases you may
need to query against a live API rather
than querying
something like the knowledgebase which
is updated less frequently so some
examples of where you would need a live
API are things like if you need to know
that what the weather is right now or if
you want to know what the inventory is
versus a big product right now or if you
want to actually place a request like
placing an order at a restaurant and
these again are either publicly
available maybe available within your
organization or you could have some sort
of partnership with another organization
to have access to their api's and in
addition to the domain metadata you also
need to collect conversational data so
this is the actual natural language text
of what a user would say something like
please schedule a call at 4:00 p.m. in
Winterfell and in addition to the
natural language text itself you also
need to collect labels for that text so
these labels are corresponding to the
models that I'll talk about but for
instance in this case a label would be
that this would be a scheduled meeting
type of request and that we need to know
that 4 p.m. is a time and that
winterfell is a conference room name and
a lot of times this data
unlike domain metadata it doesn't exist
anywhere already so it's something that
we leverage crowdsourcing tools like
Amazon Mechanical Turk CrowdFlower etc
to generate both the natural language
queries themselves as well as the
annotations and labels for those queries
and it's important that the annotations
for these queries are very clean because
if you don't have the clean label data
even the most advanced machine learning
models won't perform perform well so in
order to ensure that these labels are
clean we can do some sort of sanity
checks where we have multiple different
crowdsource workers and take the same
queries and we only accept them if
there's a certain level of agreement
between those different annotations
um so for unsupervised learning do you
mean for generating the labels
themselves or for training the full
model yeah so I when we do these sort of
crowdsourcing tasks for initially
developing the application we have to
bootstrap it with some hand labelled
annotations but once we have a model
that's trained reasonably well we can
use the output of the model as a
bootstrapped annotation and then have
crowdsource workers verify if that
annotation is correct or incorrect
rather than having to generate the
labels from scratch so in that sense it
can kind of speed up the process but we
haven't done too much with purely
unsupervised labeling right okay
but so once we collect so once we've
collected the data the next step is
actually building the model and so
there's many components of building a
conversational assistant that form a
complex machine learning pipeline so
each one of these components is its own
machine learning model that can be built
leveraging open-source tool kits like
psychic learners tensorflow and at a
high level the natural language
processor component is what extracts all
of the important information from the
query like what is these are intending
to do and what are the key words or
phrases in that query that are needed to
complete the request and then the
question answer and the dialogue manager
then generate the response back to the
user and complete any requested actions
and then if we are using a voice based
conversational assistant rather than a
type or text-based one we additionally
need two components the first is the
automatic speech recognition component
which converts the audio into text and
then the text-to-speech component at the
end which synthesizes the response text
back into speech so now I'll walk
through each of the components in the
pipeline so if you have a voice
assistant the first step is ASR
automatic speech recognition and this in
and of itself is a very complex problem
at a high level the components are from
the raw audio using acoustic features to
extract some feature vectors and then
you have a phonetic model which takes
these acoustic features as input and
outputs a sequence of characters which
represents the sequence of phonemes in
the audio and then there's a language
model which takes the sequence of
phonetic sounds and outputs the actual
understandable English language and that
takes into account a general English
English language assistance
six on what words or phrases are most
commonly said so the cost of building an
ASR system from scratch if you don't
already have an in-house solution
especially one that is better than third
party ASR systems that are publicly
available is incredibly high so in the
interests in the interest of time if
you're starting out to building an
application and you don't already have
an in-house system it makes sense to at
least initially start by leveraging a
third-party asre system like Google ASR
Microsoft speech services etc and it's
important to note that while all of
these generic ASR systems have
reportedly low word error rates on
generic English language about less than
6% on English voice search queries when
you get into the area of noisy
environments different accents like you
mentioned and uncommon terms like person
names or other proper nouns and entities
the word error rate becomes
significantly higher so we found that in
our dataset it goes up to almost 41
percent and so it's important to keep
this in mind in the rest of the pipeline
and I'll point out some of the models in
our pipeline where we are focusing on
making them robust to the sort of ASR
errors so now the first component of the
natural language processing pipeline is
the domain classifier and so domain is a
broad area of unique set of knowledge or
vocabulary for example sports is a
domain and whether is the domain music
is the domain and so the domain
classifier uses features from the
language of the query to classify an
example into one of your predefined
domains so this domain classifier is a
classification model so you can use
machine learning models like logistic
regression a support vector machine SVM
decision tree
cetera and you can also use many
different language features like
character engrams word engrams different
orthographic features gazetteer matches
etc and it's also important to note that
using these classic models work well for
all training data set sizes but as you
get very large amounts of data you can
also consider using neural network based
approaches and so now to get make this a
little bit more concrete we're also
going to consider a specific example as
we go through the pipeline so this
example is scheduled a meeting with
Janice from accounting from 11:00 a.m.
to noon and aquarelle oh and so from
this impact query text we extract
certain language features and the domain
classifier is able to classify this as
the meetings domain over one of the
other domains of expense procurement or
travel then the next component of the
pipeline is the intent classifier so
within each domain there's different
intents of what the user may want to do
for example in the food ordering domain
someone could be searching for a
restaurant by name or they could be
trying to find a particular item on a
menu or they could be trying to complete
an order a place to request and so each
of these different intents is a another
classification model which takes in the
context of the current domain as well as
the language features of the query to
then classify your query into one of
these predefined intents so the attend
classifier is again a classification
model and you can use the same sorts of
models and features for the intent
classifier but it is useful to separate
out the domain and then type
classification into two models two steps
of the pipeline because you're able to
get have both of the models focused on
different types of features in the query
and you're able to get much higher
accuracy by doing it as a two-step
process rather than trying to classify
across all domains and intense in a
single step
and then back to our example so now that
we are in the meetings domain from the
extracted features we can then classify
this as a scheduled meeting intent
within that domain the next component is
the entity recognizer and the entity
recognizer detects certain key words or
phrases which we call entities from the
query and the set of entities that
you're considering a portent again
varies by the domain and intent that
you're looking at so if you're
considering the food ordering domain and
the search restaurant intent some of the
entities that you want to extract are
things like a restaurant name a cuisine
a dish name etc and if you're in the
movies domained and the fine movie
intent some of the entity types you want
to consider are a movie title genre name
a cast member
etc and yeah so this is a sequence
tagging model so you can use models like
a maximum and true maximum entropy
Markov model a CRF or an else TM and the
types of features that you would use
vary by the type of model that you're
using but you could use things like a
bag of word character engrams gazetteer
match for a classic model or you could
use character word embeddings for more
of a recurrent neural network based
approach and back to our example so now
that we're in the meetings domain
scheduled meeting intent we note that
Janus is extracted as a person named
entity accounting is a department yeah
go ahead
right yeah so the the question was if
these domains in tents and entities are
all defined by domain experts and that's
correct so the person who's developing
the app and designing the app is the one
who's selecting what are the domains we
want to consider what are the intents we
want to consider within that domain and
what are the entities for that intent
that we want to consider and on top of
that the other point was that how do you
know if you missed something from your
domain intent entity design and how do
you add back that back in so I guess in
the development cycle engineers would
try to do their best to handle all of
the edge cases that you want to support
but as you have your model deployed and
in production if you notice from user
logs that there are certain types of
things that people are trying to do that
you don't currently support our handle
you can then go back and update your
application to handle those sorts of
intents or entities as necessary yeah
yeah and so yeah the question was I if
you get the wrong domain you're kind of
the rest of the pipelines messed up so
how do you deal with that and if
sometimes those domains can be related
and close to each other so in the design
process we try to define the domains and
intense as very distinct language
boundaries so that we don't get into
this in a situation very often where
there's two domains which have a lot of
overlapping language and so we try to
kind of avoid that problem in the design
phase however if it does happen that the
domain is misclassified the this current
system that I'm talking about will just
not be able to recover from that however
there are other systems that we are
considering that kind of can kind of do
a backtracking approach where you get
the best possible combination of all of
the classifications across domain intent
entity instead of treating it as a hard
decision from the beginning but yeah for
the purposes of this talk if if the
domain cost the fire messes up then you
won't be able to recover from that
right yeah so and the question was if is
there a none of the above option for a
domain and yes for most of our
applications we have a unsupported
domain or unsupported intent to handle
any queries that are not supported by
our applicant application design and it
can be somewhat difficult to collect a
huge set of negative samples in the
unsupported space but I think over time
we've kind of generated a good data set
since we've built applications for
multiple different use cases so we can
use the training data for all of the
different use cases and put that into
our unsupported intent or domain and
also because there there are a lot of
consumer voices systems out there and
for enterprise use cases we often times
don't want to support those consumer
intents or domains we can kind of
consolidate all of the language around
the consumer facing domains and answers
and also put that into our unsupported
domains and intent that's right so yeah
we train on negative samples yeah so by
controlled vocabulary you mean we expect
the user to say certain types of words
and phrases yeah just sort of those
start actually 30 years ago I had a
personal data as an organizer me I have
all companies the sharper image and it
asked you to specify ten digits and
certain particular words
didn't involve a keyboard at all and I
had no problems so long as it recognized
my voice because that's additional
safety wouldn't recognize Martin's voice
over here thirty years ago yes I think
so as the question is are we able to use
some of those additional contexts as
well to further improve the accuracy or
right so I think one of the reasons of
having this sort of domain intent like a
well-designed domain intent entity
hierarchy is that that kind of helps
your app to like put everything else
into the negative unsupported intent and
then really focus on like the control
vocabulary around the use case that
you're training this application for
that's also one of the reasons I think
one of the things our she mentioned that
the data collection phases in terms of
selecting the right use case we also
make sure that the kind of use cases we
are building a wise assistant for are
broad enough that they are interesting
to the consumer but not way too broad
enough that it just gets too confused
and it's trying to be an assistant for
every possible use case just all under
one application the kind of the domains
and the intents yeah so that's a there
is a one time set up initially just to
launch your like the V 1 or V zero point
1 of your app but then as you start
monitoring user logs and as you figure
out well what are the different ways in
which users are interacting with your
system you incrementally broaden the
scope of your function by maybe adding
one more entity or one more intent or
one more domain but yeah we begin with a
smaller limited scope and then expand as
we see user behavior
yes so I think that would especially be
useful maybe not so much for the natural
language processing piece but for the
speech recognition piece improving the
accuracy based on a user personalization
is can be definitely be helpful I think
that's one thing that we aren't able to
do a lot in our systems at Cisco because
these are like enterprise systems and
these are in the conference room so
literally anyone can walk into the
conference room and start interacting
with the system but this is something
that the personal voice assistance like
Siri or Cortana do try to do so they do
have a personalized acoustic and
language model that they try to build
per user to slowly add up better to your
voice so over time you should see or
whether it's slowly go down I guess for
now we haven't at least for a production
level deployment we haven't found of any
sort of really human human out of the
loop like fully automated processes we
still do have some human supervision
like we do use some techniques too and
something that our she will talk about
later in the talk of like automatically
figuring out which kind of training
samples make more sense in order to
further improve your system like using
techniques like active learning but just
because it is a consumer facing and user
facing product there is at least like
some amount of sanity checking that
humans do to make sure that we are
feeding the right kind of system to
retrain the models it's not completely
hands-free from that sense yeah so at
the recognized entities are things like
a person named for Janus Department for
accounting 11:00 a.m. and noon hour time
entities and then aquarelle o is a
conference room entity and so following
the entity recognition component
there's a roll classification component
and so the role classifier assigns a
differentiating label or relation to
entities when they may have different
meanings depending on the context so for
example in the scheduled meeting intent
the time entity type may be a start time
or an end time and similarly for a
flight booking scenario a location could
be an origin or a destination and so in
natural language understanding there's a
concept of semantic parsing which is
trying to understand the meaning of a
query based on how the tokens are
related to each other so the top image
is an example of a full semantic parse
but in many practical situations it can
be a high latency and cost effective to
train a full semantic parser and you
often only really care about certain
relation types so a very shallow form of
semantic parsing can be considered this
role classifier where we're just
considering the quantity type and
assigning that to the child entity of 6
or similarly if you had a query like
I'll have the 6 ounce soda instead of
I'll have 6 sodas then in the first
scenario 6 would be have the type of
size rather than quantity and so this
very simplified shallow semantic parsing
becomes the simple classification model
which can then be trained with a
logistic regression SVM makes that dress
yes
and so as an end user how do you signal
that there was a misinterpretation and I
guess the when we get to kind of end of
this pipeline there's a component which
is the dialogue manager which generates
the natural language response back to
the user and then if a follow-up query
is something like that wasn't right or
it's a request to do the original thing
the user asked then at that point given
the current context that's stored in
that module as well as the extracted
labels from the natural language
processor pipeline and you can kind of
correct and hopefully get their correct
response in the follow-up query the
question was how yeah I guess we can't
answer that a high level I think it's
like similar to all other it really
depends it varies from domain to domain
and intent to intend they're like
certain intends like if I were just
about to say something like walk into a
room and say join my meeting or start
the meeting that almost works with 100%
accuracy unless like the person has a
very very very thick accent or like
there's a lot of background noise and if
the speech recognition doesn't quite
work but for in generally for I guess
all of our domains are intense you can
either think of them as close to
vocabulary domains or open vocabulary
domains so for all close to a capillary
domains and interns or accuracies are
nearing like the high ninth in the high
90s but it's the open vocabulary intense
where you have a person's name or some
sort of a named entity is where yeah it
can kind of range all over the place but
yeah we still strive to before we try to
put these things into production we try
to get it to at least like the low 90s
or the high 80s as much as possible for
a representative set of users
so back to our example now in the
scheduled meeting query the time
entities of 11:00 a.m. and noon can then
be assigned the roles of start time and
end time and then the next component is
entity resolution so this is resolving
certain entity text that was in the user
query to some canonical form for example
if someone refers to San Francisco as SF
that needs to be resolved to the full
form of San Francisco California or if
someone says lemon bread but in the
product catalog it's something like iced
lemon pound cake with some unique
identifier that resolution needs to
happen so that you can actually place
the requests in API
to place that will place that order so
the way entity resolution works is it's
a text relevance information retrieval
based approach which matches the text of
the entity from the user query against
database which contains all of the
official canonical values that are
possible for that entity I guess this is
different than stemming but stemming can
be used as a feature for doing entity
resolution
so it's essentially resolving any way of
referring to an entity to the canonical
form and so now for the entity resolute
resolver this is where we really have to
be careful about being robust to ASR
errors because entities are often the
proper nouns or the uncommon vocabulary
that is most often missed transcribed by
speech recognition systems for example
in the meeting room use case if you say
can you connect me to Charon Prakash's
room that can be true transcribed to
something like can you connect me to
Koren precautious room and we found that
oftentimes a lot of the context words
are actually transcribed correctly
because they're more generic English
vocabulary
however the entities themselves are very
frequently missed transcribed and now
when you're correcting
against these miss Tran are when you're
doing the entity resolution against
these miss transcribed text you have to
make sure that your resolver is robust
to those errors so how do we do that
entity resolution and we have a few
broad categories of features that we use
the first is text-based features and so
with text features we have fuzzy
matching which is normalization using
character engrams and weird engrams to
do fuzzy matching between the the text
and the canonical forms and this takes
into account minor spelling variations
as well as typos if it's a text based
input we also have what we call semantic
synonym matching and so we have a
predefined set of semantic synonyms that
exist in our database things like pasta
with tomato sauce for spaghetti marinara
and so in addition to matching textually
against the canonical values we also
match against the semantic synonyms as
well as common nicknames and aliases
then the second broad category is
phonetic features so this is what is
essential for voice based inputs since
we are using third-party ASR systems we
don't have access to the phonemes
generated directly from the audio so
instead we use a few different
approaches including double meta phone
and graphing TIF phoneme to generate
phonemes from the transcribed text and
so double meta phone and Gotham two
phoneme are two of these approaches
double meta phone is a rules-based
algorithmic approach which generates a
phonemes and graphing two phoneme is a
neural network sequence the sequence
model which generates the phonemes and
because it is a difficult problem to
correctly generate the phonemes from
text because the same word may be trans
spoken differently by different people
people may have different accents or
just in different contexts it may be
pronounced differently by using multiple
phonetic models we can kind of have
complementary effects of trying to cover
more ground and so both of these
phonetic signals can be used
to match phonetically against all the
canonical values and try to correct
things that are transcribed to be
textually different but phonetically
similar like the two top examples in
addition a lot of ASR systems give you
not just one transcript but an invest of
transcripts for example if the user said
I want to talk with Sheetal the end best
transcripts maybe something like I want
to talk with sheet all sheet all butyl
etc and in some cases the correct name
may actually exist in one of the lower
ranked transcripts and even if not the
taking into account the end best
transcripts can give you a better
phonetic sense of what was originally
said in the audio so one interesting
example for this case is where the the
name DD is mis transcribed to a more
popular named Stevie and so this is
tricky because if someone had actually
said Stevie you don't want to mess up
that transcription but if someone said
DD and it's always miss trans type -
Stevie you need some way of correcting
for that and if you take a look at the
invest transcripts if someone had
actually said Stevie and you see that
all n of the transcripts have something
similar to Stevie you can be more
confident that they had said Stevie
versus if the top transcript said Stevie
and the remaining end transcripts all
start with the de or half-step that's
more similar to DD you can have a signal
that maybe you want to crack this to a
more unpopular name-o so third party ASR
systems give you a ranked list of and
transcripts based on how they category
is best which takes into account a
combination of the phonetic model in the
language model but it's essentially a
blackbox test and
right right oh and just one thing I
wanted to point out on the slide where
they think we probably switched the
examples this is the grapheme to phoneme
representation this would be the double
medifund representation and then the
third broad category of features is a
personalization feature so this varies
by use case but this is very important
in getting us high accuracy for example
for the call person use case we can take
into account the context of who is the
person calling and who is the colleague
so you can use things like the
relationship between the caller and the
callee based on their previous
interaction history or how close they
are in the organizational hierarchy
whether you're on the same team or the
same or a year probably more likely to
contact each other than someone who's in
a completely different part of the
organization and similarly for a food
ordering use case you could take into
account a person's order history the
popularity of a dish or how close they
are to the restaurant that that they're
trying to order from and so on so these
are just some numbers that show how
important it is to take into account all
these features so this is on our very
noisy data set that had a word error
array of almost 50% and when we use just
textual features to do entity resolution
on that that the recall at one is very
low with accuracy of 0.15 but when we
take into account the phonetic features
the N best list and the personalization
features it goes up to almost 75 percent
and also when we have the UI of a
carousel where you can kind of scroll
through and look at a few options the
usability becomes even better because
you can are even more likely to find the
person you want in one of the ranked
results and so this this set of features
transforms the app from being virtually
unusable to reasonably intelligent so
back to our scheduled meeting example
what we have all of these entities
the resolution component will resolve
the Tex Janus to the full person named
Janice Smith with an employee ID
accounting is resolved to the full form
of corporate accounting with the
department ID the times are resolved
with the time zone and aquarelle the
room name is resolved to the full form
of that room name now the next component
is a language parser which does the form
of entity grouping and groups together
entities that are related to each other
so if you're placing an order at a
restaurant and you're trying to order
pizza a calzone diet coke dominoes you
know that you want to group together the
option of extra cheese with the dish
that it's modifying which would be a
pepperoni pizza or you want to group
together at the quantity - with the item
that is modifying which in this case is
diet cokes so the language parser is
another form of shallow semantic parsing
so previously the role they were
labeling was extracting just the
quantity relation type and now in this
case language parser is just extracting
the relation groups of the head and the
child entities without worrying about
what the relation type is so in this
example a bagel with butter and worm
muffin bagel and butter are grouped
together and warm and muffin are grouped
together and in used cases where you
want both the grouping as well as a
relation label we can still use a
combination of the Roll classifier and
the language parser so in this example a
bagel and two of the muffins the entity
or the language purser will give you two
and muffins grouped together and the
previous step of the role classifier
will also have the label and quantity
under two but by decomposing this
problem in this way we're able to get
much higher accuracy with much more
limited training data sizes so in this
schedule meeting an example
Janice Smith employee-id we
be grouped together with the department
corporate accounting because corporate
accounting is modifying that person and
the rest of the entities are just their
own entity groups so up until this point
we've been extracting information and
labels from the query and now the
remaining components are about
generating the response and responding
back to the user so the question/answer
retrieved certain answer candidates from
the knowledge base which is what
contains all of the structured
real-world knowledge associated with
your domain and in our example use case
the question answer would essentially
have two calls to the knowledge base to
get all of the needed metadata of the
invitees Janus and the location which is
the room aquarelle oh and then it would
construct an API call to create an
appointment with that entity at that
location and with the specified start
and end times
then the dialog manager is what
constructs the natural language response
and directs the flow with the user so in
this case it would generate a response
like your meeting what Janus has been
scheduled for 11:00 a.m. today and then
finally the application manager is just
an underlying layer that passes all the
information back and forth between each
of these components so it first receives
the client request from the supported
endpoint it passes it through each of
the components that we've just talked
about it and then it will return the
final response back to the user and then
again if you are doing a voice based
application you would have a final
additional layer which does
text-to-speech and this synthesizes the
text of the response back into speech
and and for this case for the for the
most part third party API is work
reasonably well
that was a very high-level overview of
all the components needed to build a
conversational application and I'll
briefly talk about some concepts around
ongoing model improvement and how you
can continue to improve your model once
it's deployed and in production and this
is actually a very key piece of most
machine learning products because once
you have real user data you can
significantly improve your models and
this is how most industry leaders in the
machine learning space have become
industry leaders in that space so we can
use it sorry so we can use that what we
call active learning and essentially
what that means is that we intelligently
choose which data to select and annotate
because in production raw data a raw
user logs are cheap but still annotating
that data is still very expensive so we
can use different metrics like model and
certainty to choose the queries that our
model is currently most uncertain about
and select those ones to annotate and
add back to our training data first and
so in this graph we can see how well it
works in the the bottom blue line is
just randomly selected queries from logs
that are annotated and added back to the
training data versus the blue line is
queries that were selected based on this
model uncertainty metric and so you can
see that in both cases the accuracy
overall improves but it improves much
more quickly if we're intelligently
selecting which queries to add back to
our training data and then we can as
we've kind of briefly talked about
before create a sort of semi automated
pipeline and production to speed up the
process of of selecting queries and
adding them to the training data so the
way that this would work is that we have
raw logs coming in from users which are
going to some central data store and
then we use them some active learning
approach some monstering the T metrics
to intelligently you select the queries
that
want to annotate and then these queries
are run through our current models to
generate some bootstrapped
annotations and these bootstrapped
annotations are sent to Mechanical Turk
or other crowdsourcing workers to either
accept or reject the annotations or
update the annotations and verify that
they're correct so that after this point
we have clean verified annotations that
we can add back to our training data
then we will automatically compute the
test or validation accuracy and if the
accuracy increases we can automatically
add it to our production model and
deploy that model but if the accuracy
decreases this is where we want to go in
and do some error analysis or model
experimentation and see what's going
wrong and in some cases the this may
also involve doing some additional
feature engineering and trying to
improve the model in other ways and in
addition to continually improving our
training data set we also want to
continually add to our test data set so
that we're have a kind of a real metric
of evaluation that's evaluating against
what users are actually doing so this is
similar to the previous pipeline where
logs are coming in to a data store but
now we want to randomly select queries
instead of selecting them with some
other approach so that we get an
accurate distribution of what users are
saying but we can again do a bootstrap
annotations and crowdsource labeling and
then add those verified annotations back
to our data store as test data yeah that
was a very brief overview of some of the
concepts of why it's important to
continually add data bacterial models
and how to do that and overall we've
talked about how there's been a massive
shifts and user behavior towards voice
interfaces and we've talked about the
complex machine learning pipeline of how
to build a production quality
conversational assistant which involves
good data collection the natural
language processing
pipeline as well as question answering
and dialogue management and finally it's
important to note that these current
best practices produced reliable results
even on limited training data but as we
start as a whole as an industry to get
more and more conversational data some
of these practices may change and models
will continue to improve and develop
over time